my name is Dan Ariely and I'm the Alfred
P Sloan professor of behavioral
economics at MIT as you can clearly tell
from my accent I was born in New York
City and then when I was very young my
parents moved to Israel and I was I
lived there until I came here to grad
school and how he changed my how it
shaped my behavior so at that point in
Israel when I was growing up things were
very simple and easy and flexible and I
grew up in in an environment where could
basically do almost anything I wanted
which was great and the second thing
that my mother always had interesting
rules and regulations so for example I
was not allowed to skip classes in in
school but every time I need a day off I
could take a whole day off and my
mother's logic was that one hour here
and there and don't do much but when you
need the whole day off that can actually
help